[Music]
see that blue jumpsuit megan fox has on
as she's cuddled up with machine gun
kelly
megan and her boo apparently cut a hole
in it just so they can have sexy time
yeah it's awesome on sunday megan shared
a series of videos and photos of her
time in las vegas as she was there for
mgk's billboard awards performance
in one photo was a screenshot of a text
message that appears to be between her
and her stylist
in the message megan writes quote was
this blue outfit expensive because we
just cut a hole in the crouch so we
could have sex
her style is responding with
i hate you laughing emojis i'll fix it
last night you were catching some angles
megan giving insight to she and mgk's
private life come after the musician
dedicated his billboard music awards
performance
i wrote this song from my wife
to not only his wife megan but as mgk
calls it their unborn child
and this is for our unborn child
causing speculation that the two already
tied the knot and could possibly be
expecting
[Music]
recently chatted with mgk at the
premiere of his film good morning and
the 32 year old opened up about how love
is his greatest project while discussing
wedding planning with megan would you
consider your wedding to be the greatest
project you ever worked on because i
feel like your wheels are turning you
got a lot of grand ideas for what is
going to be a really special day for you
love is probably the biggest project
i've ever worked on yeah so yeah every
everything encompassing that i put you
know i
i give
that more energy than i give my work so
like it's harder to
work on a relationship or is it harder
to direct a film it's easy for me
to yell at corporate companies
that are funding the movies so it's not
easy to yell at my partner so like that
yeah